retour triomphal de l'ex président evo
morales chez lui en bolivie après onze
mois d'exil à ses côtés son vice
président alvaro garcia linera un exil
qui se termine sous de meilleurs augures
pour la bolivie
parce que son parti sans lui a triomphé
aux élections
il revient au lendemain de l'investiture
du nouveau leader du mas mouvement vers
le socialisme à la présidence car luis
arce et gagne haut la main les élections
du 18 octobre dès le premier tour avec
55% des voix malgré les craintes de
violences et la pandémie le vote se
déroule sans aucun incident et le
résultat est reconnu par son principal
adversaire l'ex président carlos mesa
quel contraste un an plus tôt avec
l'élection qui reportait au pouvoir une
quatrième fois evo morales
élection contestée avec soupçons de
fraudes non démontrée et la colère de
nombreux bolivien qui reproche à evo
morales sa dérive autoritaire et son
désir de s'accrocher au pouvoir
de violentes manifestations provoque la
mort de 33 personnes et des centaines de
blessés à travers le pays
la police et l'armée lâche le président
evo morales s'envole vers l'exil
ils crient au coup d'état pendant un an
un gouvernement intérimaire de droite
tentent de discréditer evo morales et
son parti le mas multipliant les
embûches pour l'empêcher de gagner les
élections
en vain le peuple a parlé et le retour
en force d'un parti qui s'établit en
bolivie aujourd'hui et qui a gagné les
élections dans des circonstances
adverses avec 55% le retour d'exil d'evo
morales commence à la frontière avec
l'argentine ou la campagne le président
argentin alberto fernandez le retour
d'evo morales se fait par la route 1000
km en trois jours en passant par son
village natal au lean au cas où jeune
homme
il gardait les lamas
il termine son périple hachey mort et
cochabamba son fief
d'où il était parti pour l'exil
exactement un an plus tôt c'est là qu'il
a commencé sa carrière politique en
défendant les producteurs de feuilles de
coca une bonne partie de la moitié
indigènes de la population lui est
reconnaissante
[Musique]
il en a sorti beaucoup de la pauvreté et
il laisse une économie en assez bonne
condition on a critiqué souvent
montréalaise par son populisme c'est qui
c'est qui est tout le temps mais miser
côté c'est la question la plus
importante c'est quel moment elle est
cependant présent à stabiliser les pays
non seulement du point de vue politique
mais du point de vue également
économique
luis arce était le ministre de
l'économie d'evo morales
il n'est pas indigène aymara main s'il
est respecté par tous les secteurs du
parti luis arce et que tout le monde
appelle lucho est un président rassurant
à cette attaque hall a un prestige
préalablement il est pas un homme
charismatique mais c'est un homme qui
inspire confiance
pourquoi parce que c'est les cerveaux de
cette conception de dell de l'économie
luis arce air promis qu evo morales ne
fera pas partie de son gouvernement
mais tout le monde se demande quel poids
l'ancien président qui en treize années
au pouvoir a laissé une forte empreinte
historique sur toute la bolivie aura
réellement sur les affaires publiques et
sur son successeur jean michel aulas
serait du canada montréal